firstly people people are very
hospitable very welcoming they have time
for you even in the busiest city in the
country Almaty it's there's not much of
a hustle and bustle so I found them to
be the local Cossacks to be very very
warm cities cities are surprisingly
modern I didn't see Nursultan I even I
heard that was even more of a modern
experiment but Almaty
was quite impressive with the
infrastructure the Metro was
exceptionally clean the city in general
is very clean but you know it was nice
it was like a nice Pleasant enjoyable
place nature so the nature even from the
largest city all Manti it's super easy
to get out of the city into the
mountains it's the start of the Tian
Shan range they're very beautiful there
are lakes
I mean 45 minutes from downtown Almaty
you can be in a world-class setting
cultural cohesion what I mean by that is
the ethnicities get along well there's a
there's a majority Kazakh population
there's a minority Russian population
roughly thirty thirty-five percent and
then there are a lot of other minorities
I didn't notice any friction between the
ethnicities and people told me also
people told me that there's really there
really are no issues between the
different races religions majority that
people are Muslim minority Orthodox and
again it seems to work just fine there
doesn't seem to be like a very dominant
over whelming feel from the church or
from Islam like people were actually out
on the weekends I found that very
interesting women were out drinking in
Almaty and there was a massive party
outside my hotel but you're free to
choose what you want to be and it
doesn't feel super strict now it might
be different in the countryside I'm sure
it is I'm sure like
some of the countryside is much
different but in the cosmopolitan
centers it works really well between the
religions location if you look at a map
Kazakhstan is sort of smack in the
middle of the world in a way it's the
largest land law country so it's really
far it seems far from Europe it seems
far from Asia I mean technically it's in
Asia but it's really neither it has
European influences and it has Asian
influences so it's a very interesting
sort of middle land of the world and it
works it works really well but it's like
nothing else I mean the Central Asian
part of the world is is very unique
safety
I felt I felt Almaty to be extremely
safe here's a crazy one for you I met
this woman and she was hitchhiking at
night in the city and they don't even I
don't think they call a hitchhiking you
just you put your arm out and there are
people cruising around working that will
pick pick whomever up that has their arm
out there not official taxis it's not
ooh BRR yeah I don't know too many
places in the world were that would be
ok where a woman would feel ok just
basically hitchhiking at night with
strangers but in Almaty that was seemed
to be legitimate and walking around the
streets super safe ok crime exists of
course I'm sure things happen but as far
as I think Almonte is 2.7 million the
metro area as far as a city that size I
felt super safe yeah I didn't feel any
edge to the place costs the costs are
very inexpensive so if you're coming in
with dollars euros yen it's a good value
I mean getting across the city
and they have something called the and
exits not uber but similar I think it
was roughly two three dollars food is
pretty cheap hotels weren't super cheap
actually that's where I spent the most
by far but still cheaper than Western
Europe for example or or us and it's not
what you think
Kazakhstan is well it's got Stan at the
end which is a curse actually
unfortunately and unjustly because most
people don't understand there there are
seven Stan countries and they're all
different and Kazakhstan is not
Afghanistan and even Afghanistan has
saved parts I don't I haven't been there
so I don't know it fully well but I can
say I can speak for Kazakhstan the name
is a curse because most people lump all
these Stan countries in to one and then
you have Bora and Bora absolutely
destroyed the image of the country it's
I didn't like it when that movie came
out for that reason I thought it was
quite unjust okay Sasha Baron Cohen is
hilarious but at the end of the day
people subconsciously we're thinking
Kazakhstan is all like the movie and
well you can see some of this footage
here in on the video I made a video
about Almaty
it's not like that at all I'm sure out
in the village in the villages you can
get into some pretty rural situations so
I strongly suggest if you're thinking of
it if you're thinking of a unique place
that's nice to travel that's interesting
it's most likely different than anything
you've seen Kazakhstan is definitely
worth a trip